All right, so the Trump administration has
released the so-called trans, the script
of Donald Trump's phone call with the Ukrainian
president in July of wenty nineteen and it's
a total joke and it is not a transcript. And
to be clear, even though the term transcript
was originally being used, eventually what
was released is a memo summarizing the call,
except it's not really a memo summarizing
the call, it's just a partial transcript with
ellipses and clearly a lot of things missing
and it is literally like I told you yesterday,
the BARR letter wo point zero so once again,
before we go any further, I need to repeat
this. The white house did not release a transcript.
They released a memo summarizing the phone
call. But in practice what it is are just
pieces of transcript I guess as recalled by
people. Even though according to the whistleblower
complaint, a full transcript does exist. It's
just been moved onto a different computer
system or computer server.
I told you they would put out a propaganda
document, it would be a propaganda document
that they will calculate is not as bad for
them as a full transcript going public and
that is what is most stunning about what we're
about to review. This is the most favorable
version possible of what took place on that
call. It is a partial transcript, a memo,
and that being said, it's still terrible and
it still confirms much of what it is that
has been alleged so far. So the question I
had after I read through it a couple of times,
which takes very little time because it's
only our and a half pages. How bad is the
full transcript that they thought. This summary
is good by comparison, onald Trump telling
the Ukrainian president that he should work
with his lawyer, Rudy Giuliani and his attorney
general illiam BARR to investigate Joe Biden
and many other things.
So let's go. Go through it. irst, looking
at the irst page, you will notice that the
irst page of the summary says the call lasted
hirty minutes from ine Oh hree to ine thirty
three am this is already weird because you
can read the transcript in just a few minutes.
Even if you double the trench, the duration
of the call of the transcript for translation,
you still have no explanation as to how this
was a hirty minute phone call. If this summary
accurately includes all of the different key
things that were discussed. Of course it doesn't.
This is a summary that has so much removed
that would be so important to take a look
at. It was a hirty minute phone call in it.
onald Trump asks for a favor. He uses the
word favor according to what's been released.
Saying quote, I would like you to do us a
favor though because our country has been
through a lot and kraine knows a lot about
it.
I would like you to find out what happened
with this whole situation with kraine. They
say CrowdStrike ellipses, I guess you have
ne of your wealthy people ellipses the server.
They say kraine has it. There are a lot of
things that went on the whole situation. I
think you're surrounding yourself with some
of the same people. I would like to have the
attorney general call you or your people and
I would like you to get to the bottom of it.
As you saw yesterday, that whole nonsense
ended with a very poor performance by a man
named obert Mueller and incompetent performance,
but they say a lot of it started with kraine.
Whatever you can do, it's very important that
you do it if that's possible. And then Trump
specifically talks about Rudy Giuliani and
attorney general illiam BARR saying good because
I heard you had a prosecutor who was very
good and he was shut down and that's really
unfair.
A lot of people are talking about that the
way they shut your very good prosecutor down
and you had some very bad people involved.
Imagine that this is how Trump talks to other
world leaders. Mr Giuliani is a highly respected
man. He was the mayor of ew York city, a great
mayor and I would like them to call you. I
will ask him to call you along with the attorney
general. Rudy very much knows what's happening
and he is a very capable guy. If you could
speak to him, that would be great. The former
ambassador from the nited States, the woman
was bad news and the people she was dealing
with in the kraine were bad news. So I just
want to let you know that the other thing,
there's a lot of talk of Biden's son that
Biden stopped the prosecution and a lot of
people want to find out about that.
So whatever you can do with the attorney general
would be great. Biden went around bragging
that he stopped the prosecution. So if you
can look into it ellipses, it sounds horrible
to me. And then there's this part that is
just crazy where onald Trump mentions that
kraine has lots of assets and that the economy
could be doing great. And then president Zelenskyi
throws it back at Trump mentioning that he's
actually stayed at Trump tower when he was
in ew York. Trump says, your economy is going
to get better and better. I predict you have
a lot of assets. It's a great country. I have
many Ukrainian friends. They are, they're
incredible people, by the way. They're wrong.
They're used in the transcript. T H E I R
Ukrainian president Zelenskyi then says, I
have quite a few Ukrainian friends that live
in the U S last time I traveled to the U S
I stayed in ew York near central park and
I stayed at the Trump tower.
So multilevel here, number ne, we predicted
exactly this. Okay. This is on the ne hand,
such a dumb conversation between presidents
of countries, but at the same time it was
never about this particular phone call. Trump
made it about this particular phone call saying,
no quid pro quo, nothing like that. We knew
we would get an incomplete transcript at best
and a dishonest ne at worst, and in the end
it's just a memo. It's merely a memo. So as
far as the call goes, you know, I saw people
like Ben Shapiro with a eventeen tweet analysis
of the call to really evaluate it. We need
a transcript or ideally a recording and we
now know that at least the transcript exists,
but it has been moved to a different server
by white house officials. The big story is
not the transcript, it's the withholding of
aid, it's the whistleblower complaint.
It's everything. That also led up to this
phone call and what we are now learning is
that this phone call was actually only something
that happened because smearing Biden was a
precondition, and we're going to have more
about that coming up a little bit later now
being reported by ABC news. Zooming out. This
is mirroring Nixon more than ever. Nixon also
released some notes about a call regarding
the Watergate break in later. It was obviously
learned that the notes were not complete and
they had been dishonestly edited. Nixon also
moved records to try to cover up the wrongdoing.
onald Trump now according to the whistleblower
complaint also has had records of this phone
call and others we don't know which ones moved
to other computer systems or servers. The
document also, it's just important to mention
to go back to the beginning, this was reportedly
a hirty minute phone call and what has been
selectively released is our and a half pages.
It takes like ive minutes to read it. The
document is filled with what look like ellipses.
Some clearly are ellipses, others it actually
is unclear whether there's an extraneous period
or whether they are actual ellipses may be
yet another thing that they can hide elements
of what was said behind these weird looking
ellipses. This is laughable. This is laughable
and it is it. It's flat out disrespectful
to the American people, be they Republicans
or Democrats or nonpolitical or whatever,
that this is ultimately what the white house
released and a, we are going to continue following
it. And we are also, I want to talk about,
okay, let me let that, that's where we're
gonna put a final point here. Let me now talk
a little bit about Donald Trump's, uh, his
delusions of grandeur quite frankly.